io mi chiami sta ammazzando mi fa male
mi fa ma retto anche la bella a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
fa vj e oggi siamo tornati in un nuovo
blog
ragazzi ho scoperto non c'entra un cazzo
di niente avanza la cosa più stupida
nella storia che potrei mai fare però
non è troppo horror questa cosa
[Musica]
egli ha poi devo sfogare le braccia per
farlo prototipo ha un effetto pazzesco
lo so adesso la di gilo così la cazzata
del giorno le ho detto ragazzi possiamo
cominciare come solito le ripartire con
la parte della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da laura che
affrontò disegno ma proprio il fatto che
sti baffi sulla fine del mondo però
ragazzi c'è la sec saggine quella vera
non si batte questo è sicuro perché non
se come ha fatto a ricordarsi di sti
occhiali li abbiamo messi un anno fa
l'ultima volta dunque fantastica
passandone news ragazzi vorrei dirvi
chiesa da parte il fatto che due
settimane fa ho fatto la gara quella di
red bull e sono quasi morto per ragazzi
primi 20 e c'e stato un punto dove mi
sono fatto male pazzesco e la cosa bella
che quando ho fatto il primo salto
quindi quello più alto ho dato una culla
tapas ce l'ho sentita ho avuto male alla
chiappa destra per tipo 8 9 giorni e il
momento era prima intera era questo qui
scelte velo deciso vedete la faccia come
molto più impegnata grande ma quando la
parabolica grande già la prima
parabolica si vanta arriva la chicane
deciso allora spiego per quelli che
dovranno farlo poi la chicane
bisogna andare vicino le palle e ora che
ci si passa dieci chilometri una
dall'altra
va benissimo è un pazzo o la presa sul
serio carriera secondo salto al vino
guarda che ha fatto tutto fa l'ingegnere
non ci credo dove d sta per arrivare
lo vedo lo vedo sta per arrivare omar
eccolo qui sto per tagliare il traguardo
ha fatto tutti gli ostacoli grandissimo
vedete è successo che al primo salto ho
dato un accurata quando toccato terra la
prima in questo momento qui è che questo
preciso momento ho dato un accurata
chaplin te l'ho sentita per 8 9 giorni
per più di una settimana ma è durato il
dolore al culo con che è stato veramente
pazzesco e 20 alle 6 non farò più la
patente dadarò questo video a chi a chi
mi dovrà dalla patente così vedrà che è
che le botte al culo l'ho già presa e
amatissima sta frase da dire prova bene
quindi ragazzi scoglio non aveva molte
gli usa oggi da dire quindi ed è strana
la cosa però va bene così
possiamo passare allo scalpello dei
pacchi che non regala secondo me
conquisterà il mondo molto presto però
voi non l'avete voi non a voi non avete
visto niente
ok oggi sono pesantissimi ragazzi li
riporti nei pennarelli ho messo il
cappello perché tipo i miei capelli
stavano andando a un'altra parte rosso
quindi non lo so lo apro perché al rosso
rosso ponsò perché promette bene poi
alla fine magari una torta ammuffita
però cosa cazzo dovrebbe essere questo e
se che mario non c'è scatenati su questo
carino figo mi piace ho ucciso qualcuno
però lasciam perdere ciaramelle fa vige
la madonna quello queste possono
passeggiare una no perché sono ammalata
tipo no grazie ho ragazzi con questo
questo ha vinto tutto come parlare alle
ragazze mi regala tesi libri perché
secondo cioè secondo voi non so parlare
alle ragazze ho bisogno il libro io sono
bravissimo nel rimorchiare non c'è
bisogno e ti va un po di schweppes
solo io e lui c'è ma si può come ultimo
ragazzi una fan art al mio al comando
c'è tanto perché lui è discriminato
quindi non gliele fanno mai
li ringrazio perché da parte sua se
molto gentile grazie cimentisti
bacchilega sembra c'è un uomo qua dentro
la mia faccia sexy e quanto è sexy
perché avete messo la mia faccia sulla
meriva to imposta sta cosa che che hanno
detto ho trovato un pacco di fazzoletti
che ho scritto fazzoletti no perché non
me ne non me n'ero accorto che erano
fazzoletti grazie allo scritto anno fa
vi fa bizzo letti giusta no perché
adesso cambia tutto secondo me ragazzi
questa non è non è nutella prova a
vedere giusto per sicurezza
secondo me non non è nutella non ci
metterei la mano sul fuoco c'è dora
l'esploratrice poi c'è un teschio a caso
lo scheletro del cazzo quando con
l'ultimo ragazzi perché oggi già tante
sorprese in questi bellissimi parchi c'è
il mondo in stoffa the sims 2 grazie di
cuore ce l'avevo però a no è una presa
per il graphic mi sembrava troppo bello
un orsetto della coca cola che ragazzino
terminato questa bellissima ce l'avevo
uguale però questo questo è seduto
questo è sdraiato di possa mettere tipo
così no perché sembra un porno un blu
ray disc manager nel dubbio non lo
aprono andati la soddisfazione che
magari a vuoto sono persi di una ghirla
è la mano tesa e bellissima ragazza
senti ma sto pacco arriva dalle hawaii o
cosa da leggo chirurgo per fermarlo
ascolta mise alte nenè futuro hanno
inventato un allegro chirurgo che è un
po meglio di questo mi riferisco tipo
ara questa 3 infilò nel a caso certo
facendo ragazzi no
no è una cazzata è meglio questo e
quello l'ultimo ragazzi anche se vi
ringrazio veramente queste sono troppo
figo che si chiama attivato in giro così
perché sono troppo swag ma assieme al fa
vi risponde perché sono carico le prime
domanda dice fini risponde qual è il
videogioco che ti piace di più da
registrare sei bella come domanda tra
l'altro il più bello ragazzi in assoluto
che mi piace di più è un eagle non è un
videogioco quello è un sito anche quando
finisco di registrare che il video cielo
pronto che sono suo amico leo con
continuo lo stesso perché mi diverto
troppo c'è proprio un gioco che prevale
sugli altri non lo so perché ce ne sono
diverse liste gamers fa vi riesce a dire
fa vj al contrario g vaff
non è facile fare il contrario perché
devo dare al volo la cadenza tipo fa vj
è il giro e ig la auris le risponde favi
quello esterno ti punto parente ha mai
reagito ad un tuo spavento è capitato
una volta che tipo è la mia madre che
dormiva in camera sua e stavo giocando
ad un horror che non mi ricordo quale
era però mi sono spaventato urlai
talmente forte che tipo mia madre
entrate in camera corsico il calcio ha
sfondato la porta
non sto scherzando e ha urlato
spaventatissima tipo che cazzo è
successo cosa così leo spiega e da lì
l'ho spiegato che io faccio lo youtuber
è stato difficile ma ce l'ho fatta poi
risponde farli maturi e connessione ai
allora io c'è una connessione è
velocissima tant'è che l'altro giorno
quando caricavo l'episodio 2 di alieni
isole shaun ho fatto uno screen perché è
memorabile sta cosa a youtube mi ha
detto 176 mila e 250 tre minuti
rimanenti per il caricamento del video o
la fibra interstellare ragazzi nella
casa verde cia vita signor verdi la casa
rossa il signor rossi in quella bianca
chi ci abita
ma sti cazzi e detto queste ragazzine
che posso la famiglia mi chiamano sto
ricordato grazie a dio da fuori domanda
di oggi ragazzi quel cappello che vi
piace no perché adesso ciò che apre con
i benvenuti mentre sta roba quale
campello preferito ragazzi tra quello
che ho in testa questo di angri perse e
pumbaa quello che voltatevi più tra
questi tre ragazzi momento in un video a
caso durante la settimana così perché mi
va di farvi di ragazzine che possono
chiudere che il video servito è piaciuto
ma se il tracciato commento mi piace
anche a pagare facebook e comunità
e stata una descrizione per sempre si
discreto di civiglio prossimo non vola
sto coso
vabbè bella ragazza qualche volta
conquisti una ragazza poi lei ti molla
la vita è dura ma tu vai avanti ma che
cazzo ci ha scritto sto libro